bonjour la voie est libre en direct tous
les samedis sur france 3 avec
aujourd'hui une question peut-il y avoir
un retour en arrière sur le mariage pour
tous comme l'a évoqué il ya quelques
jours l'ancien président de la
république et puis aussi quelles
conséquences dans la société française a
généré cette loi du 17 avril 2013 je
cite ouvrant le mariage aux couples de
personnes de même sexe pour en débattre
damien thieuleux secrétaire
départemental adjoint de l'ump de
côte-d'or bonjour bonjour françoise
verjux pelletier conseillère générale
divers gauche de saône et loire et du
cha longs longs jours patrick goubau de
la manif pour tous en saône-et-loire et
de l'association sens commun bonjour
bonjour et mathieu moreau de
l'association cigales qui lutte contre
les discriminations envers les
homosexuels bonjour et me rougeau et
vous pouvez chez vous intervenir sur
notre site internet et sur le réseau
twitter avec le hashtag f3 bourgogne et
lvl bourgueil alors je le disais c'est
l'actualité de ces derniers jours
nicolas sarkozy a étonné tout le monde y
compris une partie de son propre camp en
évoquant une abrogation de la loi
taubira alors que dans l'opinion
publique d'après des sondages le mariage
pour tous semble bien ancré 73% des
français ne veulent pas forcément
revenir sur cette loi damien thieuleux
est ce que c'est parce qu'il a besoin de
faire parler de lui dans une campagne
qui ne marche pas trop qu'il a dit ça
comme ça je pense qu'on a un petit peu
voire beaucoup caricaturé sa position
puisque on a retenu quelques mots
uniquement d'un débat qui a été qui a
été assez long la position de l'ump sur
le maillage pour tous a toujours été
clair on a toujours été favorable à
donner plus de droits en termes
d'égalité aux couples homosexuels et
hétérosexuels pour aller vers l'égalité
justement nous ce qui nous pose une
difficulté là on est on est ferme là
dessus c'est sur les questions de
filiation on est sûr de la sémantique
quand il parle de d'abroger la loi ce
que demandaient les membres de
participer à cette réunion les membres
de sens commun il faut savoir qu'on est
sur un débat juridique la loi existant
aujourd'hui est ce que l'île est de bon
ton de revenir sur la question de la
filiation à travers d un non pour la
modifier ou est-ce qu'il faut supprimer
cette loi et on réécrit une autre avec
la voir oui mais il ya la force
symbolique tout de même de l'abrogation
oui mais c'est uniquement de la
sémantique la position est claire
françoise verjux défaire ce que les
autres ont fait en politique c'est
quelque chose qui se fait souvent et
dans les deux camps est-ce que c'est
plausible de votre point de vue et est
envisageable ce que la loi a fait la loi
peut défaire
toutefois il semble que ce soit quand
même
difficile juridiquement on ne démarrera
pas les milliers de couples qui se
seront mariés on ne désarmera pas les
milliers d'enfants qui ont été adoptées
d'ici à une possible potentielle
nouvelle loi
politiquement je pense que c'est très
risqué vous l'avez dit près de deux
tiers des français sont favorables à
cette avancée de l'égalité des droits
et finalement cette loi ne donne pas
plus de droits aux couples homosexuels
que aux couples hétérosexuels
ll est à droit constant que ce soit
pour les liens du mariage comme pour la
filiation elle ne donne pas plus de
droits aux homosexuels qui on a donné
aux hétérosexuels palais de filiation
est bien sûr abordé ce aborder ce sujet
patrick goubau vous y étiez vous cette
réunion de l'association sens commun
alors de votre point de vue c'était le
fond de sa pensée nicolas sarkozy ou
est-ce que vous lui avez un petit peu
tordu le bras pour le pousser à parler
d'abrogation aubin
clairement
il ne pouvait pas éluder la question
donc il est suffisamment intelligent
pour avoir ce pouvoir
répondu convenablement problème je crois
pas un instant soit quelqu'un qui se
laisse ballotter par les circonstances
et même par un auditoire compte tenu de
son expérience comme disait damien eu
lieu il a quand même fait un
argumentaire très construit sur la
famille pendant 10 minutes qui a été
totalement ignoré des média pour un
moment donné dire que il est il envisagé
une réécriture de la loi extraite
réécriture de la loi passait
nécessairement par l'abrogation de la
loi précédente alors on effectivement
sur une sur une problématique un peu
sémantique mais en tout cas
nous notre position à sens commun et ce
vers quoi ou c'est sûr qu'on voulait
l'entendre de même d'ailleurs qu'on a
voulu entendre au bruno le maire et de
même qu'on a voulu entendre le maire qui
a été copieusement sifflé il a été non
il n'a pas été sifflé que ça en fait j'y
étais il a été simplement courageuse il
a dit très simplement je ne reviendrai
pas sur la loi taubira bon t'es
courageux
hervé mariton a été également entendus
et nicolas sarkozy donc les trois
candidats avaient été entendus il a faim
qui les a faits pour revenir sur le cas
nicolas sarkozy il a fait un argument
assez construit et à la fin il a indiqué
qu' il avait bien compris une chose
c'est que la loi taubira n'était qu'une
étape et qu'en aucun cas on pouvait
considérer que le mariage est beau c'est
le mariage des personnes de même sexe
était un aboutissement mais que
fatalement ça des boots ads déboucherait
sur
le fait qu'on ne recommencerait à
ignorer l'origine réelle des enfants
puis qu on déboucherait forcément au nom
de l'égalité des droits sur la
programmation de procréation
médicalement assistée et sur la
gestation présent pour autrui c'est ce
point là qui est le point essentiel et
sur lequel je voudrais comprendre oui
tout à fait c'est
le coeur de notre discussion mathieu
moreau est ce que ça vous a étonné parce
que il ya des questions qui se pose
justement on le dit mais finalement le
mariage de maintenant il est voté il est
à qui donc est ce que est ce que l'idée
d'un retour en arrière vous a étonné ou
pas moi ce qui m'étonne c'est que la
première fois qu'on a eu ce débat sur
l'atome avait invité s'il ya deux ans et
on se posait la même question et je me
rends compte qu'on fasse au bout de deux
ans il n'y a pas grand chose qu'à
évoluer quoi c'est à dire qu'on se rend
pas compte que ya plus de sept mille
couples qui se sont mariés qu'il ya des
adoptions qui sont en cours que la loi
les massivement
approuvé par la part notre notre société
dans les sondages le prouvent encore
régulièrement donc lui un peu estomaqué
que des responsables politiques soient
encore en train de se poser la question
savoir s'ils sont pour ou ils sont
contre parfois avec un peu
d'électoralisme quand même voix ce qui
se passe pour la campagne de nicolas
sarkozy moi je vois où ça beaucoup de
démagogie dans ce qui est dans ce qui
est raconté par ce que prétendre revenir
sur une loi aussi fondamental que celle
ci ça me semble un petit peu ambitieux
on voit l'exemple espagnol la droite est
revenue au goût au pouvoir sont pas
revenus sur une loi identique je me
posais un petit peu de la question du
vue du pourquoi du comment
3 comment aussi beaucoup et puis
j'aimerais qu'on se pose aussi la
question de des conséquences que cela
pourrait avoir une telle abrogation en
termes de création d'inégalités de
victoire de l'égalité entre les couples
qui seront mariés des coupes qui
voudront se marier nous ne pourrons plus
là c'est pas le conseil constitutionnel
qui nous et qui nous retrait serait
peut-être la cour européenne des droits
de l'homme je pense qu'il faut faire
attention aussi à saint françois unger
je veux tu donnes mathieu oui je
souhaitais rappelé l'exemple espagnol
2005 la promulgation de la loi et puis
sept ans pour que finalement le conseil
constitutionnel disent 'elle est
constitutionnel et donc que la droite
populaire espagnol le parti populaire
espagnol la droite espagnole renonce
finalement à l'abrogation de cette loi
c'est pas que de la sémantique
abrogation pour moi c'est pas que de la
sémantique c'est un mot lourd de sens
juridiquement et on ne peut pas passer
comme ça
d'un revers de la main des propos tenus
en meeting devant des milliers de
militants et mais aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux et moi j'ai écouté
l'argumentaire conçu sur la famille sur
l'amour is un peu empêtré les pieds non
je pense qu'il a cédé à la pression
d'essence comme tu le voulais
oui on a quand même il ya eu un débat
dua vote
une loi donc l'émanation des citoyens
français et je reprends ce que dit
mathieu moreau on a le sentiment qu'en
réalité c'est moi qui ai pas acceptée
par une partie du monde politique et du
monde à ceux de la manif pour tous mais
là vous parlez monsieur moreau de
démagogie je préfère parler de valeur
donc on a effectivement certaines
valeurs vous elles peuvent différer
entre vous et moi mais au moins qu'on a
les valeurs on les tient et on va
jusqu'au bout de nos valeurs et là où je
parlais mois démagogie c'est sur sept ce
choix qui a été fait par le gouvernement
socialiste d'aller dans la direction du
mariage en tant qu'institution
institution qui est quand même connoté
sur un plan religieux qui est assez qui
est assez stricte et vous avez
aujourd'hui beaucoup de couples qu'ils
soient hétérosexuels ou homosexuels qui
ont préféré une forme le plus souple
plus simple qui était le pacs qui était
une avancée et cette forme là du pacs
aujourd'hui n'offrent pas les mêmes
droits et ces personnes là vous les avez
laissé sans avancée en termes de droits
et protection par rapport à leur
conjoint que ce soit les couples
homosexuels ou hétérosexuels d'ailleurs
quand même surpris de votre part de vous
rendre d'étendre le pacs ligne aussi lui
qui a été copieusement défendu par votre
camp à l'époque donc c'est toujours
assez assez drôle d'entendre à des
personnes qui n'ont qui sont battus le
défend aujourd'hui je suis ravi de
l'entendre parce qu'aujourd'hui le pacs
concerne une majorité de couples
hétérosexuels donc c'est à dire que ce
qui était dit à l'époque est était déjà
fort et ses coûts plus nombreuses plages
de production juridique ce qui me pose
la question c'est que c'est que
effectivement aujourd'hui pour vous
pensez réécrire qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que ça va quoi ça va consister qu'on
veut concrètement quoi voilà c'est fait
pour nous refaire le coup de l'union
civile réservé aux couples et aux
couples homos je vous rappelle aussi que
deux fois avec monsieur sarkozy est
amnésique que ça a été retoquée par le
conseil constitutionnel et que dire on
va faire un mariage pour zobo un mariage
pour les hétéros pourquoi pas un mariage
pour les blancs pour par mariage pour
les noirs aussi on peut se poser la
question ce sera également et pour les
mêmes raisons retoqué donc voilà il faut
rester se poser la question des des
conséquences de ce qu'on annonce patrick
bouveau on le sait les pays européens
sont jamais revenus en arrière en
général furent les réformes sociétales
on sait aussi qu'en termes de droits là
c'est un petit peu précis mais par
exemple la cour de cassation raisonne en
termes de jurisprudence appliquée c'est
à dire que quand on a avancé sur un
certain nombre de points ne revient pas
en arrière objectivement vous le savez
il ya peu de chances qu'ils à une
abrogation réalité un 13e de chance on
sait qu'il y aura une rupture d'égalité
devant la loi et que sa disposition la
france sera condamnée de toute façon par
l'europe si ça arrivait et la hiérarchie
des normes juridiques en empêchera ce
retour en arrière vous poser deux
questions vous poser une question dans
du juridique et il ya une dimension qui
voudrait bien qu'on abhorre de vie si
c'est la dimension sociétale la question
d'ordre juridique on peut en débattre à
l'infini de savoir si un droit accordé
une catégorie population peut être
retirée ou pas la jurisprudence et les
constances c'est que il ya rupture
d'égalité et donc et donc des sillons
négative on sait constitutionnel dacourt
a pas de gp grenoble s'il ya rupture
d'égalité entre des personnes dans une
situation identique à un moment
identique là en l'occurrence on serait
vis-à-vis de personnes effectivement une
situation identique mais pas un moment
identique je prends un exemple vous avez
un permis de construire dans une zone
non constructible
certaines personnes ont pu bâtir dans le
passé et puis tout d'un coup la loi dit
bo vous pourrez plus bâtir les ruptures
d'égalité entre les personnes et on va
pas demander aux gens qui avaient une
maison avant de la démolir sauf sauf
extraordinaire donc là aussi les
juristes peuvent se battre à l'infini le
point n'est pas là le point il est
surtout vous ai cités tout à l'heure
elisabeth guigou et le pacs le point qui
est important dans cette affaire c'est
que le débat sur le mariage pour tous
n'est en aucun cas terminé quand bien
même la manif pour tous n'existerait pas
pourquoi parce que tout simplement ce
mariage accordés à des personnes qui
sont biologiquement incapable de
procréer puisque naturellement deux
hommes ou deux femmes ne peuvent pas
avoir d'enfant ensemble je pense qu'on
sera tous d'accord là dessus ce mariage
l'année en aucun cas identiques au
mariage entre des personnes de sexes
différents en conséquence de quoi les
droits vous dire ça je dis c'est mon
fils mon malheur est extrêmement non ce
n'est pas un jugement de valeur c'est
tout simplement une réalité biologique
est en train de vie rares chizé de 2,2
union deux amours de quel droit sur
quelle base vous pouvez vous nous
annoncez sur une base strictement de loi
naturelle simple qui fait que deux
personnes de sexes différents cris de
joies de la nature aujourd'hui dans la
république c'est moi je crois au gré de
la république je crois pas aux lois de
la nature mais vous savez si aussi si
aujourd'hui si aujourd'hui vous dites
qu'un arbre et parler avec vous foncer
dedans dans votre voiture même si la loi
dit que l'arbre et par là vous serez
quand vous aurez comme un grave accident
donc il ya un principe de réalité qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui un enfant a un papa
et une maman donc la situation dans
laquelle on se place est une situation
dans lequel on prive délibérément un
enfant de connaître son papa et sa maman
si on lui prétend que il est le fils de
victor dupont et de jérôme durand on
sait que c'est pas vrai et lui sera très
bien quand il aura 18 ans qu'on lui a
menti partant de là si ces
revendications
aboutissent on ira forcément vers la pma
la gpa au nom de ce principe d'égalité
que vous vous que vous proclamez donc ce
que je veux dire à travers cela c'est
que ce mariage pour tous vous dit le
débat devrait être clos et juridiquement
il le sera et un effet cliquet peut-être
les juristes diront si cela mais sur le
plan des fondamentaux sur des valeurs de
la société on ne peut pas se contenter
de dire les choses on s'arrêtait leur
jeu contrairement aux outils une fête
vous m'amenez vers la suite de notre de
notre discussion mais vous me regardez
méchamment ressaisir jeu mais vous allez
pouvoir réagir
et maintenant vous avez tous envie de
répondre mais effectivement vous ouvrez
sur la suite on a parlé du mariage il ya
tout ce qu'ils avaient pas effectivement
non dans la loi sur mariage les
différentes conceptions ceux qui
disaient on ne doit pas le mettre dedans
parce que ce sera une conséquence
juridique on ya vu aussi françoise
verjux pour certains une forme de de
lâcheté un petit peu de ne pas avoir
voulu parler justement de la procréation
médicalement assistée on se rappelle que
c'était un engagement du candidat
françois hollande
maintenant ces choses là est ce qu'elles
doivent rentrer dans une loi de votre
point de vue est ce qu'il faut
laisser la justice française et
européenne agir parce qu'en fait c'est
en réalité ce qui est en train de se
passer
d'abord je voudrais rappeler
mon interlocuteur de en face que on
parle du mariage civil on ne parle pas
du mariage religieux
et notamment pour l'église catholique
les valeurs morales les valeurs morales
aujourd'hui sont celles d'une république
laïque et je voudrais rappeler que et
elle a fait un très beau discours la
ministre christiane taubira il a
expliqué ce qu'était le mariage civil et
comment le législateur
au moment de 1791 à intégrer à instituer
ce mariage civil et les débats très
violente que cela va entraîner
le mariage excluait d'abord les non
croyants
puis les non croyants catholiques puis
les les les professions un comédien
qu'on veut pas se marier donc 1781 c'est
une vraie révolution sens qu' il ya eu
égalité et c'était la liberté c'est
d'abord une loi de liberté et moi dieu
m'est étranger et j'ai la liberté de ne
pas me marier et il ya quand même le
phénomène de consentement dont on oublie
de parler qui montre c'est une loi de
liberté et moi je veux je veux dire que
finalement cette loi parachève deux
siècles d'évolution du droit civil et de
cette institution qu'est le mariage
civil dans une république laïque où il
était anormal que des personnes ou qui
avaient d'autres orientations sexuelles
que celles préconisées par l'église
catholique majoritaire en france jusque
encore aujourd'hui soit interdite
d'accéder à des droits ils soient
discriminés par rapport à cette
orientation sujet j'avais envie dire le
code du travail est finalement plus en
avance que sous le code civil puisque
ils interviennent les discriminations
sexuelles al embauche par exemple on
remarque que le débat sur le mariage
chrétien et puis
moi je suis étonné qu'on soit à re
débattre des ses shoots la loi vous
proposer de parler de la pma
la joie est là elle la pma pour répondre
la pma nous ne ne fait n'autorise pas
les couples hétérosexuels
tous les couples hétérosexuels avoir
recours à la pma la loi est claire pour
je les écoute un procréation
médicalement elle se dit que j'aurais
sûrement médicalement médicalement
assistée a assisté quand il ya un des
deux membres du couple qui est infertile
pour une raison médicale tous les
couples hétérosexuels non pas adroit à
la pma et comme c'est le même mariage
qui est proposé aux couples homosexuels
il n'y a pas plus de droits ils ont les
mêmes droits et donc ils n'auront pas
plus de droits à la pma que les couples
hétérosexuels aujourd'hui
moi je voulais revenir un petit peu sur
sur cette question de valeur parce que à
chaque fois qu'on a la manif pour tous
sur un plateau il faut faire un petit
peu de chance de duplication et de
sociologie parce que manifestement les
mises à jour sociétés ne sont pas
complètement remonter dans notre cité de
2014 je vous informe ce qu'il ya
aujourd'hui une diversité des modèles
familiaux que vous le vouliez ou non
c'est la réalité vous parlez de vous
mettre le principe de réalité je vous
informe que il y à des milliers de
familles homoparentales qui sont
constitués soit garçons soit deux filles
mais il ya aussi nous vous en déplaise
des familles monoparentales à qui on n'a
pas mon petit du tout à ces enfants là
parce que ben voilà les choses la liste
- défendez séparée et que ma des
familles monoparentales qu'est ce
qu'elle soit vous faites uniquement d'un
papa ou une maman c'est exactement la
même chose pour nous on n'a pas à les
hiérarchiser et à les mettre dans une
bulle de voter la société je pense que
vivre dans une société en 2014 qui est
respecté l'ensemble de cette diversité
là parce que vous vouliez ou non encore
une fois hélas deux personnes du même
sexe sont tout à fait capables de
s'occuper d'élever un enfant et croyez
moi pour avoir accompagné et connaître
des complots qui ont ce projet là où
qu'ils ont abouti et bien le désir
d'enfant c'est pas un caprice parce que
adopté aujourd'hui
c'est un parcours du combattant même
pour les couples hétérosexuels
donc il faut pas non plus se tromper se
tromper de débat et puis voilà
concernant ces principes éducatifs moi
je trouve que je suis éducateur et donc
que je vais faire de l'investigation
dans des familles qui ont qui sont
confrontés à des difficultés
croyez moi la diversité aussi à
l'existant et je crois qu'il faudrait il
faut vraiment s'en rendre compte faut
pas tomber dans des stéréotypes d'un
autre temps voilà et sur la question de
la paix et moi moi je ne vois pas
forcément comme une suite logique mais
je voudrais qu'on en discute parce que
effectivement je vois pas pourquoi si la
pma et éthiques pour les couples
hétérosexuels
elle ne le serait pas pour les couples
de femmes voilà moi je pense que c'est
qu'ils morte dans les mêmes conditions
les couples de femmes devraient avoir le
même droit sur la gpa c'est un autre
débat je vous rappellerai que la gpa
pour sonne pas uniquement les couples de
débat n'est pas un débat mais il est pas
n'est pas que pour personne monsieur et
pas uniquement pour les associations
lgbt pourriez pas que les français en
ont marre
la gestation pour autrui c'est un débat
qui devrait avoir lieu à l'échelle
nationale et surtout le type de famille
pas uniquement pour les couples homos
c'est fait l'audi dette qui n'est pas
d'ailleurs forcément une de leurs
premières revendications je vous
rappelle quand même que à l'époque de la
présidentielle quand les associations
ont écrit des et des plateformes de
revendications sur ce qu'on voulait
la gpa n'était pas inscrite en tant que
devant question tant que tel parce que
le débat même en autres ça les
associations la fédération de
m'accrocher il est pas encore français
donc ayons le de façon saine et porte de
façon stigmatisant envers les
associations et les couples de même sexe
pour pour relancer le débat et je vous
fais part de mes messages qu'on voit
tomber et qu'on affiche à l'antenne on a
eu beaucoup de messages disant vu l'état
de la france il ya autre chose à penser
que relancer sujet est ce que patrick
goubau et c'était mon idée pour vous
poser la question
finalement est-ce que les français sont
réellement intéressés par ce dont on
commence à parler c'est à dire la
discussion sur la procréation
médicalement assistée ou pas compte tenu
du moment et la question vaudra bien sûr
aussi pour vous damien thieuleux la
tribù vaut d'abord c'est très clair que
les français n'attendait certainement
pas que le nouveau président de la
république s'occupe de ses sujets qui
sont absolument pas prioritaire dans la
tête des français on le voit bien
d'ailleurs le son monte lui qui n'ont
absolument pardonnez moi le mariage pour
tous faisaient qu'une partie de la
campagne électorale très fortement
aventin fois au plus fort de la crise
quand même à bien je pense que ma mère
je crois pas que ce soit pour sa
françois hollande a été élu il est des
gens parlent de maintenant maintenant la
rue michel-ange la crise ce sujet ce
sujet a profondément divisé la société
française il ya quand même eu trois fois
un million de personnes dans la rue il
ya quand même eu sept cent mille
signatures envoyée au conseil économique
et social qui les a purement et
simplement mises à la poubelle sur
instruction du premier ministre il ya
quand même eu une mobilisation
extrêmement forte d'une jeunesse qui
ressemble terriblement à mai 68 d'une
certaine manière puisque c'était c'est
vraiment la jeunesse de france qui s'est
levé pour dire on est en train de
toucher à quelque chose de fondamental
ou call le monde politique ne devrait
pas toucher alors évidemment
j'annoncerai droit de m'approcher de la
table
donc il ya quand même eu et on a refusé
un référendum sur cette question donc
vous dire ce débat est apaisé qu'il est
clos s'est certainement pas le cas
maintenant je vois je suis exactement
comme les français je trouve absolument
inadmissible que le gouvernement actuel
qui met la france à genoux qui pour
lequel le show matin le long l'emploi
est un échec la défense nationale est un
échec la diplomatie internationale est
un échec la france n'a plus perspective
plus d'espoir les jeunes foot le font à
l'étranger par milliers et on est en
train de nous expliquer aujourd'hui que
les réformes sociétales sont le coeur
l'alpha et l'oméga notre politique
évidemment les français attendent autre
chose il n'en reste pas moins que l'on
ne parle pardonnez-moi mais justement on
reproche à françois hollande ne pas
vouloir faire de réformes sur la pma la
gpa dont justement il en fait plus de
réformes sociétales mais il fallait
faire vous avez vous allez monsieur
importer de l'eau à mon moulin je vous
avais dit mais non effectivement le
débat n'est pas clos forcément il n'est
pas clos il est normal qu'à partir du
moment où l'on dit à des couples
homosexuels qui n'ont par la nature par
la capacité de procréer je pense que
vous tout le monde sera d'accord là
dessus il est normal que ces gens là on
leur dit vous avez les mêmes droits que
les autres dorénavant il va pourquoi les
autres ont des enfants et pourquoi pas
nous ça me semble tout à fait logique
pardonnez moi c'était déjà le cas très
largement je cherchais les chiffres d'il
ya dix mille enfants qui vivraient dans
des familles homoparentales en france
donc de toute façon la situation allait
déjà il y avait une situation antérieure
mais certainement c'est d'ailleurs entre
parenthèses je voudrais quand même temps
dont le coût a quelque chose il n'est
jamais été question des mariés les
couples homosexuels il faut quand même
pas qu'attirer caricaturer les choses
jamais été question de cette de ceux ci
et là pour le coup constitue helmand ça
serait impossible il n'a jamais été
question de faire d adopter les enfants
qui le sont déjà selon il est question
c'est de dire il faut absolument reposer
les godasses réfléchir sur cette
question donc reconsidérer la loi
l'abroger où l'art écrire ça veut dire
la même chose et pour réellement savoir
faire quoi cela en maine et cela nous
emmène inéluctablement excusez moi c'est
ma position à la création d'orphelins
légaux et c'est ce point que nous
voulons dénoncer
vous expliquer justement c'était
l'engagement numéro 31 du président
actuel de la république effectivement
pas ce que je regrette c'est qu'il n'est
pas appliquée le point 1 jusqu'au point
30 et puis les points 32 et suivants il
sait absolument uniquement concentré sur
7 sur cette réforme sociétale c'est la
seule chose qu'il a réussi à mettre en
place dans ce qu'il avait annoncé le non
dit 30 engagements sur 60 à mi mandat je
trouve que c'est honorable avec un
chômage qui explose avec elle en
obligeant qu'avez vous fait pendant dix
ans on peut faire le débat sur le
chômage et sur les la dette française
s'est passé souvent sur ce plateau
je pense voilà c'est pas en deux ans et
demi mais c'est pas la priorité des
français d'avoir ce débat sociétal et on
voit ce qu'on disait en ouverture damien
thieuleux finalement est ce que les
responsables de l'ump que vous êtes sont
très à l'aise sur ce sujet c'est à dire
entre la manif pour tous qui clairement
voudrait que le débat se poursuivre ça
fait partie des 20 et puis finalement
une un moment qui n'est peut-être pas
très favorable à ça alors que vous êtes
en campagne interne et tu as une
primaire est effectivement d'abord ce
débat qui a eu lieu avec avec le
mouvement sens commun
s'intègre dans une campagne l'élection à
la présidence de l'ump c'est pas le seul
sujet qui est débattue au sein au sein
de cette campagne entre l'avenir du
parti des propositions et et tout ce
qu'ils ont ce qui en découle il faut
aussi le reconnaître en 2007 c'est un
engagement de nicolas sarkozy de mettre
en place l'union civile pour les couples
homosexuels vous allez d'aller plus loin
bloqué par le conseil d'aller plus loin
en termes de en termes de droits et
l'égalité c'était comment à l'époque en
2007 mais c'est partager l'intérieur de
l'ump ça te poser c'est est une position
qui avait été accepté au sein de honnête
qu'elle fouille en vrai elle faisait
débat ou faire maintenant parce qu'elles
avaient été nombreux à faire que quand
vous avez un un candidat à la présidence
de la république le programme est écrit
en amont oui le mariage pour tous
amateurs du parti socialiste avait aussi
des gens qui n'étaient pas forcément
pour le sens de ma question était un
jour sur quand vous avez quand vous avez
une famille politique forcément quelques
voix qui peuvent être dissonante dans un
sens ou dans l'autre mais c'est un
engagement qui avait été pris qui n'a
pas été appliquée parce que à ce moment
là on a on a préféré au niveau du
gouvernement se concentrer sur la
gestion de la crise et sûre sur les lois
économiques plutôt que sur des lois
sociétal qui divise
alors on a parlé de pma vous le disiez
il nous reste cinq minutes avant les
infos de midi puis après on parlera
aussi la manif contre tous mais un mot
sur ce qu'ils menaient nulle part qui
n'était pas dans la loi c'est la
gestation pour autrui est ce qu'on est
encore quand on parle de gestation pour
autrui donc pour faire simple pour
caricaturer ses les mères porteuses
gestion pour autrui entre autres nous
regardent et mathieu moreau j'admets que
je caricature violemment mais
est-ce qu'on est finalement dans le
débat sur le mariage pour tous sur ce
sujet là où est-ce qu'on n'est pas
complètement complètement pardon dans
l'autre chose moi je crois qu'on nous
attribue à tort cette revendication
comme étant notre notre notre destinée
finale notre objectif prioritaire
s'était beaucoup agité pendant le débat
il faut que bah c'est pas la première
fois que l''indice pour tout s'agite des
lanternes mais effectivement on l'a vu
pendant ces deux dernières années et ce
qu'ils vont nous on considère que l'
envie de faire une gba déjà elle
appartient aux couples qu'il soit homo
ou hétéro je le rappelle est que
effectivement elle pose des questions
qui sont bien plus transversal est bien
plus large que la simple question
d'égalité voilà ça pose évidemment des
questions éthiques
la thématique de la marchandisation du
corps ceux des arguments auxquels nous
sommes sensibles aussi et donc qu'on
continue qu'on nous attribue de façon un
peu rapide expéditive cette
revendication là moi je ne suis pas
d'accord parce que effectivement le
débat a encore vieux aujourd'hui au sein
de l'association d'abord et puis au sein
d'autres d'autres univers militants
aussi voilà moi c'est ce que je regrette
c'est que nous n'avons pas assez
suffisamment débattu de ce que ce qui
fait sa mue aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que
faire faire mieux est-ce que c'est
porter le même nom est-ce que c'est
avoir le même sens on sait très bien que
c'est pas du tout le cas c'est même plus
aujourd'hui habitée de sous le même toit
donc essayons un petit peu de faire les
mises à jour sociétale de ce qui fait sa
mue et ensuite décidons de commande
également on peut protéger ces familles
et les enfants qui en découlent parce
qu'il n'ya pas eu l'impression
finalement à gauche au gouvernement que
la société était mûr pour le mariage
pour tous et qu'on pouvait faire
l'impasse sur ce débat dont parle
mathieu moreau c'est à dire la filiation
la parentalité toutes ces choses là je
pense qu'il a été sage de s'arrêter au
mariage pour tous qu'il est on l'a vu
accepté 19 pays le pratiquent
aujourd'hui et on n'est vraiment pas
précurseur
dans la matière sur la question de la
filiation il ya eu des très grandes
réformes je rappelle que un enfant n'est
plus ou naturels ou légitime c'est aussi
une des évolutions de ce mariage civil
et de cette filiation et je crois que
ce débat sur les droits de l'enfant les
droits de l'enfant doivent être
approfondies en france je rapelle que au
regard de la convention internationale
des droits de l'enfant la question de
l'accouchement sous x 1 et de la
protection du secret des le secret des
origines pose question et ces questions
là doivent venir en débat dans la
société française
personnellement la gpa effectivement je
crains très fort la marchandisation des
corps des femmes est on le sait un
l'évolution des droits
les femmes elles sont les premières
victimes quand il ya régression on voit
que depuis deux siècles et il ya un
mouvement de laïcisation
et d'aller vers plus de droits et puis
un mouvement conservateur qui tente à
vouloir reprendre des droits il ya des
périodes le divorce a été abrogée en
1816 et puis il a été réinstaurée
rétabli en 1880 cadre on voit que lee a
sans arrêt cette tentation de revenir en
arrière bon bien tu le mets dans dix
secondes c'est la fin de cette émission
donc on réattaque rappard votre réaction
juste après les informations de midi qui
vont nous être présentée par un hollow
fabre et on se retrouve juste après pour
continuer le débat sur le mariage pour
tous et aussi sur la manif pour tout ça
tout de suite